make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay you know one of the best things
about being a comic-book youtuber is you
guys you know other made in the past I'm
not super knowledgeable on spawn and I'm
kind of learning about it as I go
through it and I cover it I covered
spawn issues either the first section
rights like the origin of spawn and then
like the second part and then like the
origin of Angela and then a lot of the
guys were just like no Rob like just go
with spawn number 154 and just read
forward right like just read Armageddon
basically like all you need to know is
that spawn and Swanage Neil Malvo Jew
basically ended up dying spawn it up
killing him he was offered you know
Malvo his place in Hell spawn said no
because he didn't want to be part of
Hell he want to do his own thing that's
all you need to really worry about right
just cover Armageddon I promise you will
not be disappointed
dude this story is lit it's amazing this
is why I'm so glad I have you guys right
this is why I'm so glad that I have you
guys see you guys like when it comes to
something I'm not really familiar with
you guys can be like no Rob go read this
instead so so here's the thing give me
suggestions on like spawn and like other
stories and other things that are not
Marvel and DC give me suggestions about
that kind of stuff cuz you guys seem to
love it and I'd love to go check those
things out right like I'm mostly just a
Marvel DC guy right like I don't really
bit my toe out of the waters but
nonetheless you guys don't care about my
stance on comics you guys are here for
spawns war against heaven and hell okay
there are a couple things to know going
into this right we already covered one
of them that essentially malabo jizz no
longer part of the picture right like he
was killed and spawn issue number 100
and in his place came a guy named Lord
Mammon I think is what his name was now
Mammon is one of the Fallen ones and
those are kind of be explained a little
more as we get through this but the long
and short of this is that when it came
to the fallen ones in the end the spawn
universe and I do not know how true this
is to actual biblical storytelling but
the idea was that when the war between
heaven and hell broke out that there
were angels who supported God but chose
not to fight and the result is that they
were basically cast out of heaven but
never actually sent to help Mammon as it
seems to be the exception right he's one
of the rulers of hell and he's more
powerful than mal Bhoja is the other
part of this is there's what's called
the man of miracles and then there's Sam
and twitch
now Sam and twitch are really kind of
like the sidekicks of Spawn not in the
sense of like Robin or anything like
that you know Robin for Batman but
insofar as like their supporting
characters in the story but Sam and
twitch in the 1990s
were huge people loved salmon twitch
right lady look like like the bickering
that went on between the two of them and
that kind of thing so eventually they
spun out into their own series which was
hugely popular I'm pretty sure I think
it was like a massively popular series
but people loved salmon twitch the idea
is that they're kind of detectives right
so they basically helped spawn out in so
far as there are things going on out
there and it's like okay spawn can't
really figure it out on his own or they
can provide him with information you
couldn't readily get on his own
different things like that now the man
of miracles is ambiguous if you know who
he is please do not tell anyone right I
know who the man of miracles is we find
out but please do not tell anyone who
the man of miracles is but one of the
first big instances of the man of
miracles encountering spawn was when he
basically removed the kid named named a
kid named Chris and the idea behind this
is that Chris was that was essentially
seem to be some aspect of spawn himself
that could basically reach in and grab
other personalities out of spawn now why
he has those personalities and how we
got them will be explained over the
course of this video but what we do here
is really kind of jump into the meat and
potatoes right because you guys want to
kind of get into this sort of thing and
one of the things spawn establishes
right off the bat is he is not an agent
of heaven and he's not an agent of Hell
but he's not working with either force
and that's what makes things kind of
interesting is because todd mcfarlane
depicts the conflict between heaven and
hell almost as like rival gangs each
one's trying to take over the other's
turf right like the angels and heaven
want to get rid of like the forces of
evil and the forces of evil want to get
rid of like heaven and all the angels
and God and all that kind of stuff you
know and so there's sort of always
warring against each other
spawn after the death of mal Bhoja and
the power that he possessed following
that basically put him in a position to
where both sides were jockeying to get
him to their side right because of the
power he possesses and what it is that
he can do and so because that he's kind
of like I don't want to have anything to
do with this anymore right like I'm
doing my own thing I'm not fighting for
either side and so the result of this is
that he's basically giving you and in an
attempt to essentially stop the
apocalypse stop the end-times from
coming he's giving these kind of
locations my Sam and twitch about things
that are popping off now what they say
is most of these skirmishes are being
dealt with by like local police but
there are some that are exceedingly bad
and things are kind of going nuts and so
the result of this is we end up jumping
to basically Joshua Creek Tennessee what
we have here are essentially the dead
rising to life right the Dead coming
back and then just you know kind of
cannot really resuming their lives the
way they did but like kind of maintain
their personalities there were things
along those lines
but
this is really one of those instances
where it really does look like the
apocalypse and so is spawn arriving on
the scene we pick up with this guy named
Hiro Sheik it's amaura and this guy's
not really given us we're not really
given a lot of story here all we know is
that somewhere along the line that this
guy basically died in addition to him
there's also a young woman this brought
a line I brought along as well by the
name of Kumiko now for the most part all
they've known is darkness for a pretty
lengthy amount of time and for the most
part they were seemingly yanked out of
the body of spawn by Christopher himself
and so the result is that he basically
he basically tells these two guys you
all are going to be endowed with some
measure of power you guys are here to
help me you know essentially quell this
threat right these undead zombies that
are running around this city and so it's
kind of interesting because Kumiko is
more or less obsessed with video games
and her grandfather is a lot more
traditional insofar as he's kind of like
the slow-moving guy right like analyze
the situation figure out what's going on
don't just rush in head-on whereas
Kumiko just grab some guns and just
start shooting the place up and the
reason why is because for her she used
to play this game that you that really
had her just like wiping out zombies in
a game called zombie wipeout and so she
got really good at killing zombies so
it's kind of like her thing right is her
repertoire now there's a reason for why
it was that she was chosen here along
with her grandfather but once they get
in here they immediately just start kind
of unloading right you know you have a
grandfather who's just tearing
everything up at least slicing heads off
and so on you've got Kumiko you know
shooting everything up that she possibly
can and things are kind of popping off
pretty quickly the issue with this is
that as the situation begins to unfold
and as they begin to really take on
their true forms because this is all
happened within the span of minutes
right so their bodies are still
transforming from how they look when
they first pop up to when they really
start to gain these powers and more or
less become their spawn selves more or
less or spawn versions for lack of a
better word but coup because of course
surrounded by zombies and then she's
ultimately saved by her grandfather and
then once they get inside this place
this creature who had essentially called
all these people together and who was
saying hey guys like you know all we
have to do is pray everything will be
fine
that ultimately of course being consumed
by zombies now for the spawn series
being as religious as it is the fact
that like God's not answering their
prayers is a big hint to what's going on
well we'll find out what it is it's
taking place here in a second but it's
one of these things were like with these
characters being essentially brand-new
and that's not really getting a lot of
them aside from the fact that like
they're killing zombies and kind of
going on a warpath that they're that's
when she begins to realize the reason
why they're beginning to look the way
they do kind of decayed breaking down
things like that is
they are in fact debt and that's when
the grandfather realizes I'm the one who
killed her like he killed his own
granddaughter that kind of seems to have
been the case that's where things are
sort of popping off here we end up
learning there's a handful of things
that are going on the first is that
humanity is crying out for God to say
that right this place Joshua Tennessee
Joshua Creek is not the only place where
things are going wild it seems to be the
only place where the dead are rising but
it's not the only place where people are
sort of panicking and looking to God to
save them from whatever it is it's
taking place that nobody that that
essentially God is not answering
anybody's prayers that heaven itself is
under siege but the reason why God's not
answering anybody's prayers is because
God is not there the throne of heaven is
empty no one knows where God is and so
what we do here is we pick up with
essentially the angels of heaven right
these warrior angels now you guys will
probably remember them from our origin
on Angela we didn't really touch too
much on them after that and in reality
what you learned in that video is really
all you need insofar as they are the
individuals who are charged with
protecting heaven against whatever the
invaders would would come to its
doorstep namely the forces of Hell but
the fact of the forces of help are so
huge in number and the forces of heaven
are dwindling so fast
really all points to the idea that the
forces of Hell are going to win outright
everybody in heaven is simply going to
die at some point hence the reason why
the character of Zahra has basically
been resurrected now the way in which
her character plays out is really cool
right what we end up learning here is
that somewhere along the line Zahra was
an agent of heaven and was really
considered to be God's most loyal
servant she had a bloodlust that was
really uh none challenged nobody was on
the same level as she was when it came
to like destroying enemies right she's
an exceedingly powerful member of the
heavenly Pantheon the issue with this is
that once her bloodlust takes over it's
like Thor in his warriors madness all
reason and logic go out the window and
all she wants to do is just destroy
everything and so because of the fact
that she was kind of considered to be
this sort of chaotic concept insofar as
her going being sent out into the field
and then killing these various forces
would require God to monitor her all the
time and then eventually reel her back
because she wasn't really in control of
herself ultimately this basically led to
God imprisoning her from the time that
he sort of began to realize that she was
uncontrollable essentially up until now
when she's been freed now this kind of
begs the question why didn't God just
fix her so she's sure she could be
controlled I don't know probably for the
sake of the story but regardless her her
rage manifests in the form of like this
giant beasts of war but it's this idea
that the angels of heaven really look at
her and say with her being on the
battlefield now let's hide his turn
because she's more than enough to take
out all these forces these these from
these members of the Forgotten of Lord
and Mammon who are all basically trying
to lay siege to the gates of heaven and
so following that what we end up doing
is basically picking out - you know all
these individuals who have been more or
less massacred by the Hindu goddess Kali
at least I believe is Hindu the way is
kind of depicted here that sort of seems
to be the case but Before we jump into
that what we end up doing is picking up
with the man of miracles and the man of
miracles essentially visits spawn and
it's kind of interesting because a man
of miracles will sort of make these
appearances here and air and now again
if you know who who the man of miracles
is please do not spoil anything we will
find out in the next video but the man
of miracles basically says that like
that really isn't going to be a way for
you to stop us you can if you want to
but at the end of the day you're going
to need Christopher to make this happen
right like talk to Chris he will know
what to do and so again these are kind
of ambiguous here there's a lot of
questions popping up that we don't
really get definitive answers to but we
will so do not worry right so the next
thing that we end up doing is basically
you know having Christopher travel back
into spawn and then sort of end up in
this giant desert plain out with these
two individuals and and what we end up
finding out here is that the man's name
is a mall and the woman's name is Shanti
and they've basically kind of existed
here they sort of recognize where they
are to a degree insofar as they seem to
basically be part of spawn but it's also
this idea that their karma is more or
less tainted right in their loaf is
really tainted in the traditional sense
and so far as like they did bad things
to people but it's is this idea that
they cannot truly cross over and the
reason why is that for them they're
still holding on to this kind of earthly
presence try this this thing that still
binds them to the earth as it exists now
and the reason why is because once
they're yanked out and they start having
this conversation with spawn what they
say is according to their belief system
they follow something called The Book of
Vedas right these this book that really
gives people a kind of direction a sort
of compass when it comes to wisdom and
the things that they can that they can
read that essentially contains the
legends of the gods that in the religion
itself that it follows a process whereby
they they die in they're reborn multiple
times in an effort to basically achieve
Nirvana to essentially achieve spiritual
perfection and that according to these
legends that Kali was created out of
pure light to battle the forces of
mahishasura
I think it is I apologize if I've missed
bounced that but basically to battle his
forces of darkness the issue with this
is that as Kali began to battle these
forces she began to become corrupted by
her bloodlust right this idea of just
originally destroying and killing
everything and so in response to that
her husband Shiva essentially laid
himself down among the dead and then she
came to believe that she had essentially
killed him and so in that moment she had
basically sort of experienced a kind of
of sympathy right a kind of pain for
what it was as she had done but
ultimately this whole thing is just a
more or less a myth as how they refer to
it but it's really an allegory it's not
designed to be taken literally it's just
designed to show how easy it is one when
it comes to the forces of good and evil
two how easy it is to fall to the evil
side right how easy it is to stray from
the path of righteousness more or less
and become the worst version of
themselves now this is where things sort
of shift because what Todd Miller I
guess not really timing for him is David
Hein he writes this but what he ends up
doing is like shifting the whole thing
on his head and saying no Kali is very
much real the other part of this is that
kylie's really depicted as being on a
pantheon of power while not necessarily
tied directly into heaven and hell' into
g judeo-christianity she appears to be
on a level of power that's higher than
that of Spawn right this is all kind of
stated by way of Haqq the Swan doesn't
immediately get into a conflict with her
and kill her but also kind of you know
things like I can destroy you easily if
I wanted to right I could annihilate you
in your entirety if I wanted to right so
that kind of seems to be the case that
in reality if she's just that much more
powerful then spawn himself and so
following this you end up getting this
this interesting sort of situation right
where spawn kind of rehashes what is it
he's doing when he basically says I'm
here to prevent the apocalypse and she's
like well you can't you can't prevent
that why would you try you're a hell
spawn you're supposed to fight on the on
the side of good or evil really on the
side of evil that's your purpose and his
response is well I choose who I fight
for this is kind of cool because what it
shows is that even though Callie's not
really part of the day of Christianity
it's all something everybody is aware of
right so it's very similar to Marvel in
that regard right insofar as you have
like the the sky father that's why
you've got Odin you've got Zeus all that
kind of stuff they're aware of who they
are right it was just this great big
huge sort of shared space and that's
kind of a cool thing to see what is it's
it's interesting it kind of changes the
way that you see the story to a degree
but the long and short of it is that
essentially you end up having this deal
that's kind of being struck that shanty
and her husband really say like
basically Kali says I will leave this
place and I will spare spawn if you're
willing to give up that which you value
most that which means the most to you
and the result is that we kind of learn
their origin story and will be end up
finding out is that somewhere along the
line the shanty and her husband were
basically expecting right she was
pregnant with a child and that as they
were making their way to their parents
house they ended up going around this
mountainside this bend and there was the
the road was too thin really for them to
avoid a truck that was coming around the
result was that they were knocked off
the side of the mountain and they ended
up dying and so when they present the
child to Kali the response of Kali is
well this child's neither alive nor dead
right this child is be is reborn from
whatever it's life was before but the
fact that it hasn't been born mean it
hasn't left its previous life but it has
not started its new life it's just kind
of stuck there in a state of limbo and
while the parents realize this at the
end of the day it's their child and they
just don't really have the heart to let
it go but because of the fact that there
are much bigger things at play here and
because achieving their ability to move
beyond their current forms and
potentially pass on and even reach
nirvana they end up giving up their
child they end up sacrificing their
child to Kali who basically says I'm
giving this child the gift of death
therefore it can be reborn again in
whatever form it's going to take and so
satisfying this bargain Kali basically
leaves Kali walks away and allows Fon to
continue on his journey now this is
where things really begin to pop off
this is where things really begin to get
nuts and the reason why is because what
we do here is we pick up we can kind of
cover that origin story of Kimiko right
so the Oranje story of her and her
grandfather for those of you guys who
were interested you're just story here
is that when they were alive basically
they were of course alive in the modern
era but the grandfather was very much
beholding to Japanese tradition right
early said that seems to be the case
when he talked about Bushido cultures
but the tradition of respecting one's
self and the people around them that all
went into it his children were a little
more progressive insofar as they
considered the beliefs and the teachings
of their father to be old hat and then
you had Kumiko who was even more
progressive than that and as far as she
was concerned she didn't really care
about the traditions of her grandfather
and she was at that rebellious age where
she was like I just want to go and do I
don't think my parents just won't
understand me that kind of situation and
so as a result of that we end up finding
out that her grandfather had actually
been following her for a few weeks
whenever she left the house and he
considered what she'd done to kind of be
disrespectful but more so than that he
basically wanted to save her that what
he had discovered is that in her private
life that she had basically been going
to like nightclubs bars different things
like that that she'd been going and
engaging in drugs
she'd been prostituting herself to pay
for drugs and so she was living this
pretty horrible lifestyle and so
traveling to essentially this drug den
in order to save her what he ends up
doing is of course showing
there with a samurai sword he in turn
you know kills with a guy who answers
the door and then everybody else starts
opening fire right and so ultimately
Kimiko jumps in the way to save the life
of her grandfather and their grandfather
perishes as well but that's how all this
went down right is is pretty violent and
in pretty extreme but that's how all of
this ended up going down but the real
meat and potatoes of this and the really
the most important thing comes with the
twins Jake and Katie of Terry and Wanda
Fitzgerald now slowly guys who are not
super familiar with this and this is why
I think covering the origin story was so
important after Al Simmons was killed
and then he was basically resurrected as
spawn during that was a five year eight
year time period before he ended up
returning that Wanda believed he was
actually dead and so believing that he
was dead she married his friend right
married his best friend because he was
there for her when she needed him that
kind of a thing and so while cyan is the
daughter of Wanda and Al Simmons Jake
and Katie are the children of Terry and
Wanda themselves the issue with this is
that following their birth they've been
displaying these almost kind of
psychotic tendencies right like wanting
to destroy things different things like
that they've been putting magnets on the
fridge and it said stuff like kill mommy
things along those lines
and so Wanda ends up coming home after
the babysitter is keeping an eye on the
kids and then like essentially you have
like Katie who bashed in the head of
Jake with a baseball bat smashed his
head in and Wanda immediately starts to
freak out but the crazy thing is that in
the midst of all that Jake basically
gets up right in this head starts to
heal everything starts to go back to
normal and Wanda has no idea what to
make of it all but while that was
happening when Jake was unconscious she
had called the cops and basically said I
think my child is dead and that kind of
a thing and it all just sort of went
nuts after that when when the cops show
up as far as they're concerned Jake's
got a scratch on his head and the
explanation is well Jake seems to have
fallen and bumped his head that's how
they that's how they assumed things went
down but of course Wanda tries to
explain everything to Terry that
something's wrong their kids are not
their kids something's not right
right things just aren't making sense do
they've always kind of displayed these
crazy tendencies and it's really
becoming more then Wanda has been able
to handle and so all this basically
comes to a head when you end up having
the twins who basically grab a knife and
they end up tying up Wanda
along with with cyan and then just kind
of like stick him in there right I mean
they've got like the dad tied up so like
Harry's tied up they're all basically
tied up and the twins look like they I
mean they go they have like a gun things
are about to pop off right like these
are about to get kind of nutso they they
seem to have kind of lost their minds at
the very least
Terry starting to see what it is that
one has been talking about about their
kids being crazy this entire time and so
following this we switch back over to
Zira
and zerah did exactly what she was
expected to do which was basically just
lay waste to the forces of the Forgotten
and essentially destroy them all and so
ultimately because the you know all the
Forgotten ever believed to have been
destroyed she asks them how does it feel
to be the last one left are there any
more of you and before this person gives
the name she snaps the guy's neck and so
as a result of that you know you end up
basically having the other angels who
were there kind of watching everything
unfold it's like okay this is kind of
nuts but like what do we sort of do here
you know and and basically it's this
notion of her basically saying like
we're gonna initiate the rapture with
Heaven's forces being depleted we're
gonna recall all those from Earth who
were faithful to God and when the
response is but only God can initiate
the rapture and God's not here we don't
know where he's at
then zeros response is then I'm gonna go
find him I'm gonna go find God the next
time you see me God will be at my side
and so what you end up having here is
you basically end up having Kali you
know kind of picking up with with her
character only for Kali to basically
transformed back into the man of
miracles right so that kind of seems to
have been the case that the man of
miracles essentially went to go test
spawn or whatever the case says we don't
really know what the reason behind this
is but he's kind of amusing to himself
about everything that's going on it says
there's truth behind all of these
charades everything that's going on from
the time that Al Simmons became spawn up
until now has all been part of a plan
more or less it's all been part of a
greater plan that's what he's hinting at
and saying there's truth behind all of
this but only one can set everyone free
a child will save everyone and that's
what we're basically given this kind of
perception of what what basically ends
up looking like cyan as that's where
things sort of go nuts because what we
do here is we end up picking up directly
with spawn and his guys who are just
kind of having this conversation and
what we end up getting is this
explanation of why spawn had like people
inside of them you know when you have
spawn and you have Zam and twitch and
Christopher and like and all these guys
all having this conversation what we end
up learning is that when Al Simmons died
that essentially around 6,000 other
people all died within the same hour and
for whatever reason that those 6,000
other people were all bonded to spawn
but this is the reason why it is that
where spawn didn't know that they were
there back in the early days that mal
Bhoja could not control spawn he could
not make spawn do whatever it is that he
wanted to do that mal Bhoja was trying
to control 6,000 people and not
realizing that and that kind of seems to
have been part of the plan the man of
miracles was talking about although
we're not entirely sure now as far as
Sam and twitch go with their
investigations only about 2,000 names
have been found but what this means is
that spawn is armed with
all these individuals who can
essentially help him along this path in
his war against heaven and hell and so
that's when things kind of get
interesting because from there you
basically switch back over to Towanda
and you switch back over to Sian and you
switch back over to Terry and all these
guys and you have the kids who were just
like okay so like let's kill him like
let's do our thing I mean why not just
kind of giving in to their darker and
twisted selves and so where things start
popping off and it's this idea that
they're just gonna kill him and they're
gonna take these guys out suddenly spawn
pops up and when he does it's kind of
like okay so like essentially saving
yeah Wanda and Terry from Jake and Katie
and Sian who looks like she's basically
on her deathbed more or less looks like
she's about to die assuming like he's
going to save them the issue with this
is that when he goes to kill Jake and
Katie under this idea that what Wanda's
telling him is true that they're not
that really their children they're
possessed by something or or somebody's
got them screwed up you know possessed
by demons whatever the case is who knows
the spawn goes to try to take him out
and they cannot die you know initially
it's believed that they did the chains
pierced them you know they come crashing
down Terry starts freaking out Neil
calls him a murderer and believes that
they're dead but ultimately they're not
right they end up getting back up again
and then suddenly there's this huge kind
of rattling sound and literally zero
just comes smashing into the building
and what it's just like who in the heck
are you right when Jake responds like
who in the hell are you then Zahra
immediately bends down and says I am
your faithful servant and it's like who
in the heck is she and basically Katie
says yes now I remember who I am you
know and and Jake stands up and says I
do too
my name is not Jake what this all points
to is the idea that the son the son of
Wanda and Terry is none other than God
himself what being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to come this explained make
sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob port if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like man the story is amazing and I will
catch you all later
FUS I want to say thank you to all of
the new patrons who have joined
patreon.com slash comics explained I
want to give a shout out to Henry young
- Elias G David J s Jacob H been John H
Jason see Austin s Austin H James O
kristymatt in Jeff are Joey em Stephen Z
sloth-like lu-david see John H lean and
mean that guy asked questions all the
time
Adam Cajun gnosis 9/16 I want to say
thank you to all of you all this list is
growing all the time they were joining
the patreon
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]